dr grace padilla is the medical director
of one of the leading public hospitals
in manila
she says health workers across the
country have been overwhelmed
by the pandemic but today at least there
are some signs of
progress it's the second day of public
inoculations against
covid19 and she says this
is what gives those working on the front
line
some hope this vaccination is the
solution for this disease
so there's no other way to fight 2v19
but through vaccination vaccination is
the solution for the nation
at this hospital at least 1300 medical
workers are receiving their second dose
of vaccine
people here tell us they have to line up
for hours but it's something that they
don't mind
they say because in a country with more
than 100 million people
they tell us they feel grateful to be
inoculated now
the government is facing delays in its
national inoculation drive
due to limited supplies and its own
initial restrictive
policies towards vaccine imports but it
now promises to inoculate around
70 million filipinos by the end of this
year
for the country's health community this
cannot come
soon enough the philippines is facing a
steep rise in coronavirus cases
hospitals intensive care and isolation
bed facilities
have reached critical levels
42 healthcare workers we are already
preparing to augment the shortage of
medical workers in manila by sending
some from nearby provinces
this is something that we expect in a
matter of days
forcing the government to re-impose
tighter restrictions
it had already implemented one of the
strongest and strictest lockdowns in the
world last year
and many here have grown weary of what
they see as the government's
tough stance in fighting the pandemic
but for nurse assistant
flori bulan getting her second dose
means she is able to worry less
about infecting her own family
vaccinated now it feels like liberation
day
so now i can really focus on taking care
of my patients
i am happy a glimmer of hope she says
in what otherwise appears a very
desolate
situation jamela lindogen al jazeera
manila